remind me I haven't done this in a while
so you might want to watch out
Oh take two hello sport Bible my name is
Kyle Walker this is the Tiger Woods and
we are going to play trick questions
here's the ball all right let's get
going
okay go what's the biggest moment you've
experienced in your career well I think
one in the 97 Masters was probably the
biggest because I was able to win by 12
it was my first major as a pro and I set
up things for the rest of my career
what's the most funny story that you've
got from playing that not many people
know about well I've got a bunch of them
but one I've saw a guy hit a ball into a
poor John which is kind of funny right
in line right in wasn't one Wow
definitely a hole-in-one what's the
toughest thing about playing golf I
think the toughest thing is just a
mental challenge of it all you battle
all your inner demons out there while
you're playing there's no one to bail
you out this is you against yourself
obviously the golf course and players
should play against but you have to
overcome yourself before you can
actually want to go from and what is so
special about the Ryder Cup
well the Ryder Cup is its unique because
what we don't really don't get a chance
to play team events very often
especially different formats being for
ball and foursomes and also it's you
know the bipartisanship of the crowds
that's something that we we as golfers
don't face very often the obviously
therefore the people they want to see
win but it's never like it is during a
Ryder Cup and obviously you're an
amazing golfer but if you could have
chosen any other profession to be even a
golfer what would it be I probably would
have followed my father's footsteps and
been in the military really a you
stopped with the keepy uppies less so
and more and more all right see some
more and can you show us the best
trickshot you can do with a club and a
golf ball come with this one the best
one you've got what only one I get I I
can kind of somewhat do is the baseball
one and see if I can you remind me I
haven't done this in a while so you
might want to watch out let's never go
it why not all right
take two
thank you so much later what a trickshot
this is Kyle Walker for sport Bible have
a great yeah thank you to that
[Music]